hi everyone it's lucy and i am joined by
tamor hello everyone and uh yeah we're
just doing voiceover today because we
figured that you would want to look at
some brand new death loop gameplay which
is what you're looking at right now um
we have
the we have the game and so we're here
to give you the final preview on death
loop after both spending a big chunk of
time with it tam how long have you
played for about about six hours uh
meticulously playing through it so not
progress far but have put in a bunch of
hours into it yeah i'm about the same
i'm about six hours in um i have
done some runs at some visionaries i'm
not exactly proud of my uh my stealthy
side is very upset at me because i've
literally just ran in gunned them down
and taken their slabs to unlock some new
powers so we can show them off in this
preview
um if you're worried about spoilers
don't be this is gonna be a pretty
spoiler free zone there's gonna be no
puzzle solutions or anything like that
um it's just more to talk about
how the game is uh shaping up because
it's obviously just on the horizon and
how it feels to play and what uh what
the buzz is with arcane's
latest so tam let's talk about the
design of it because i think it is the
most
complicated like but beautifully
designed game
and i'm so intrigued by it yeah there's
a
an elegance to its design that is really
really fascinating and it's i mean like
we said we're very early in the game so
um who knows whether it sticks uh stays
that way over the course of the game but
i'm confident in like the building
blocks of the experience are placed in
such a smart way that um it feels like
it warrants really really like um deep
kind of analyzing and the thing that i
love about it most is or i'm in loving
about it most is they've clearly looked
at
these types of games and what makes them
interesting these um loop based games
and you know roguelites roguelike
um and kind of taken all the core
um pillars of
and aspects of them that makes them
really um
satisfying and rewarding to play and
then they've deconstructed what makes an
arcane game really interesting to play
and it's almost like they've married the
two like ingredients and then put them
back in the game but like spaced
everything out so you're
so you're kind of experiencing them at a
really
like deliberate pace and you're you're
you're interfacing with different
aspects of of the design
and a step-by-step process which is
incredible because i think that the
thing that i i would say is for me so
far if you if you're the kind of person
who's played these sandbox um type
immersive sim games but never understood
especially why dishonored why they why
are they people really love them this is
the game that basically it feels like
it's designed to tell you why
dishonored is amazing
and it's fascinating because you'll go
into a level and you'll have a specific
objective and you'll be like oh what's
my specific objective it's you know to
kill this person or get this piece of
information and because of that the way
the game is designed you're forced to
kind of look at the clockwork nature of
the world
and then you're like okay
but and by doing that you learn
something about the way the game is
designed and constructed you learn oh
this these people they behave in this
certain way they have this routine and i
can exploit it using this and early on
in the game
if you're a player like me who steals
everything
you don't have access to any of the
powers that would let you behave that
way so in my first six hours i've been
very unsuccessful at stealthing because
i don't have the powers needed to do
that properly like the you know the
shift and the double jump and that kind
of stuff so effectively you have to go
in guns blazing at certain times like
it's really difficult to avoid that it
is doable and i have done it but it's
very difficult so the game is forcing me
to play in a way that i traditionally
wouldn't have played um a dishonored
game so that i can build up my character
to the point where i can then play it in
the way i would have played a dishonored
game and that is like so so clever and
so so fascinating yeah because i
wouldn't have in a normal dishonored
game i don't do guns blazing but i and
so that means i've played those two
games without firing most of the guns in
the game or killing most of the people
in the games but here i have to do it
but it's almost freeing it's such a
smart and amazing way to design a game
yeah and um i mean so
you'll you'll hear us call it smart and
because it is and it's
it's a game that requires a lot of
attention like i would fully recommend
playing with subtitles on because a lot
of the times people are talking at you
over a tannoy over a radio and you as
cult are very much just just as unaware
of the world that you've been dropped in
as um as you the player are and so it's
like so much to take in you're obviously
learning so much because you know you
have this one loop you have to kill all
the visionaries in one single loop to
break it um and to do that you have to
gain information that sticks with you
over time loops
and that's and that's also like your
arsenal right it's like you get powers
you get weapons you get um
trinkets and trinkets um that kind of
build up your character and so in order
to keep those over loops um one of the
early missions has you
um
investigate a way to hold on to things
over loops and like once you start doing
that you start investing in yourself as
a character um your your weapons and
your loadout um by kind of finding this
um
uh this stuff called residueum and then
you kind of so it's like no loop is ever
wasted because
you can go and you can say oh i'm gonna
find this piece of information i'm gonna
find this dorky or i'm gonna kill this
visionary and get their slab and if you
kill the visionaries over and over again
you get the slabs and that powers up
that ability and so
everything in there
is just really smart nudges to never
feel like you as the player languishing
and it also just like
it feels so good like it looks gorgeous
and i mean like the void engine has
always been beautiful and i think as
well particularly arcane games
have such a very distinct like they have
such fantastic art direction
and i think uh def loop in particular
it's like
that
60s sci-fi
with like the oranges and the the music
in it is also great but like the void
engine looks looks great and it also
feels so nice and like
dual sense integration is never the
be-all and end-all i think it's a really
cool thing it's like really cool to have
um but like weapons feel great and and
it's weird like you were talking about
it earlier it's like you never really
approach an arcane game like this with
guns blazing but i found myself doing it
more not just because it's like oh this
is just a quick loop i'll go in i don't
i can't be bothered to still think i'm
just going to go and kill everyone and
then i'll just grab something and leave
it's because the weapons like feel
genuinely really good and now that i
have a few more powers than you do i
have shift which is basically blink i
have havoc which is uh just uh you take
less damage you deal more damage i have
ether which makes you go a little bit
invisible and then i also have a nexus
which chains people together and then if
you kill one you kill all and so now
like i could just jump in with those and
i'm having like the mix of them i'm just
having a blast yeah i think the the
thing that i love about this approach is
it encourages you to
look at like i said earlier like you
take uh strategies that you ordinarily
wouldn't and
and it kind of lays bare uh the the
world itself um and the whole point like
you said is to gain an understanding of
how everything works in the world to the
point where you are able to
do one continuous loop through all the
environments of the game at all the time
periods of the day and kill every
visionary and the way it does that is
kind of like how i would play
a stealth game or a something like a
hitman where you go into it and you kind
of section you chunk the level in your
mind where it's like this is my current
objective i'm gonna focus on this and
then i'm gonna come at you from every
perspective possible to see how it all
ticks and then once you have an
understanding of that you kind of gain a
mastery over it and then you move on
it's weird but it's kind of like doing a
fighting game combo especially a long
one where fighting game combos you know
there are a lot of button presses and
the way you get good at that is you
break it down you do the quarter circle
punch and then you figure out the timing
on how long you wait for the next punch
to come in to keep the juggle going and
then you keep adding more to it until
you've got the full combo completed and
that's what this whole game is about
it's like go into one thing go in with
one objective think about it here look
at every parameter that's available to
you master it and then move on to the
next part of it and at the end like i
assume
it's gonna be so satisfying to put all
those pieces together and then and then
you know uh do one quick run through it
and i am so so like i can't stop it's
one of those games where it's like i
can't stop thinking about it and i want
to keep playing it and i'm annoyed that
when i'm not playing it i am i should be
playing it it is like these sleeping
dogs why do you not have pokemon in your
hand um i always want def loop in my
hand one of the one of the visionaries
that you go after is harriet and like i
was messaging you last night and we were
like well how did you do it i was like
oh i did this this and this and you were
like well i did something completely
different that i didn't even you did the
smart thing i did a thing which was
incredibly reckless and i was like this
might not work but let's see what
happens and it was exactly the case of
why i love arcane games i had an idea
and it doesn't seem like i was like
there's no way this works and then i
tried it and it worked and i was like oh
okay cool so now i know like the the
entire rule set of the world has changed
because of what i've learned based on
experimentation and the reason i was
able to do that experimentation is
because i had done that area a couple
times so i knew it pretty well and now i
can come back at it with more next time
i do it i know that solution is there so
i don't have to worry about all these
different things like taking ages to
figure it out and i can just steamroll
through it which is really really
rewarding when you make those
discoveries yeah and i mean because as
well like uh those words written on the
world they kind of gently point you in
certain directions but it's like you
said it's like it's it's partly me
trying to forget the the game language
of dishonored and you know now
learning the game language of death loop
and what i can and can't interact with
what powers and abilities will work best
together and it's just like
i think one thing that's really
important to mention is that like you
never feel
as though you're a dead end because you
have four different maps you have four
different times of day there's different
things to do at different times of day
and genuinely you never feel like
a block and each time is wasted and they
do very clever things as well to prevent
you from getting stuck you know like
that they outline for you the game
outlines for you to keep pointing you in
the right direction without explicitly
telling you what to do so it's
yeah i'm i'm i'm in love with it yeah
and and the other thing is like the the
uh within each area there are big
objectives that take a lot of time and
investment and there are small
objectives that are just like almost
like a hit of instant reward and
gratification as simple as like hey just
be here at this time and this this door
is going to be open i've learned
and and you do something like that and
it feels meaningless but um
actually you realize they're like
they're really important to that feeling
of growth and
progression and understanding because
you walk through that door and then you
suddenly realize oh this store leads to
this thing so if i come here at this
time i can get here way quicker and it
is like like
this isn't exactly an original take but
like this is a game that teaches you how
to speed run the game very slowly and
that feeling is really really
fascinating because
you also kind of like get to learn
get to experience something that very
few people are able to right like
speedrunners are kind of a special breed
of gamer um where they they understand
they see games in a way that few others
do and you get a taste of what it's like
to play a game as them in this you start
to feel and understand what is and it
also kind of like like i said it makes
you feel like a fighting game player
where you're learning these things and
it makes you feel like it teaches you
how to really appreciate a an immersive
sim and
i fully foresee people
playing this game and then going i'm
going to go back and play dishonored
which is basically like a very similar
experience but given to you in a very
different way in terms of design but
also linking together because there is
so much information chucked at you about
this world about the visionaries and
about what everyone is doing there that
you are piecing together like i have a
little notebook
of stuff going on because which i
haven't i don't do that for games
whereas arcane i feel like in death loop
has hit this amazing middle ground of
giving you just enough but without being
too obtuse yeah and so when that all
comes together it just feels amazing and
it's also like it's worth saying is
it is a stunning game in terms of like
how it looks but also the weird
characters that are there and
i'm doing similar things because like
i'm keeping track of everyone and you
learn so much about their like uh likes
dislikes tendencies they put it in the
game but then as like a note that you
find but then you also when you run into
a visionary and watch them for a while
you'll learn things about them and it's
worth writing those down so the in the
mission that we did which is harriet and
carl's bae um harry is just like mad
cult leader self-help guru that is like
gassing her followers and
doing really weird [ __ ] like that and
she's you learn a lot about the way she
uh kind of thinks and behaves and use
that to her to your advantage um and
it's you need to know that because you
know when you go to take her out she's
in her compound surrounded by a lot of
followers and if you don't know what
you're doing you can very easily find
yourself getting killed over and over
again but if you take the time to learn
about her observe and see what she's
like you can make that that whole uh
encounter so much easier
you want to be good at it and it
everything the game does pushes you
towards mastery and it's i love it and
i'm
super excited to see where it goes i
think as well just in terms of
narrative the way that all of the
systems and narrative intertwine it is
very much like the pepe sylvia
uh charlie from it's always sunny with
the board with the red string behind him
and then at the end just screaming like
there is no carol in hr that's how i
feel like trying to play this game and
trying to are you reading my preview
again
carol
uh no and i i'm i'm just so excited by
it yeah it's um
genuinely uh something very very special
and i'm like we didn't play the
multiplayer multiplayer isn't turned on
uh for us at the moment uh but i'm i'm
very intrigued just to kind of go and be
a menace and all my friends yeah i think
like um and and also i i know we
referenced my preview but um we're not
going too deep into the setup or
anything like that because it hasn't
really changed from the last time we saw
the game which was a hands-off uh
preview so if you do want a more like
broader look at what's going on and how
it looks and that kind of stuff you can
hit up the game spot and search for my
deathly preview it's there and the same
still goes from that this is more
focused on how it feels and how it fits
together and like lucy said yeah um
i'm cons
consumed by thoughts of it and it is a
genuinely fascinating game and
um it shouldn't come as any surprise
given that it's arcane and they just
seem to just put out banger off the
banger but i am so glad that uh it is
the way it is and
it feels good to be like a really really
enamored and really really like obsessed
with the game again it's been a while um
so shout out to arcane good job so far
yeah i'm loving it all right that's the
final preview then for deathly game
comes out on september 14th for more
make sure you stay tuned to gamespot
head over to gamestop.com to read tam's
preview from a couple of months ago um
if you listen to gamespot after dark
this week our podcast we will definitely
be discussing more of death loop then
actually if you have any questions stick
them in the comments and we'll answer
them on the podcast
tam where can people find you you can
find me on twitter at timor h come and
tell me about your favorite arcane
moments
and i'm at lucy james games see you next
time